hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video I'm
going to talk all about the rise of
ancient Valyria as well as the future of
the Targaryen Zin the books George our
Martin has just teased that after he's
done riding a Song of Ice and Fire
he's going to do a book just about the
Targaryen x' supposedly it's going to be
called fire and blood it would be a
historical book about their families
starting in ancient Floria with the
beginning of their house all the way up
through Daenerys we don't really know
what her fate is going to be in the
books but if you read any of his short
stories I think that it'll read like
those instead of the POV style like the
Song of Ice and Fire novels just a real
quick reminder I know you guys really
like this my weekly book giveaway for a
world of ice ax fires still going on all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so just general spoiler warning
for everything through season 4 on the
show as well as everything up to book 4
that's pretty much where season 5 starts
is like right at the beginning of book 4
with a few exceptions so let's start
with a breakdown on the rise of Valyria
world of Ice and Fire add some nice
context what was previously discussed in
all the regular novels cool fact dragons
at one time covered the planet they
weren't like a swarm of locust or
anything just imagine how as predators
they flourish during a prehistoric
period when geographical conditions were
favorable and they were the apex
predators people know this because
dragon bones have been found all over
the world not just in the warmer parts
of Westeros and eastern continent
dragons are critical to the rise of
ancient Floria but they predate the
Valyrians by a long long time Valerians
as we know discovered them roosting in
the 14 flames the peninsula volcanoes
here at the south end of the Eastern
continent this is the area that became
the Valyrian freehold the freehold took
a long long time to coalesce even though
the books make it sound like it was an
overnight thing
think of Valyrian slur nning to bond
with the dragons like the Dothraki
domestication of horses is not really
the same thing dragons were never
domesticated but as close as you can get
to domesticating dragons as that started
to happen Valerians became much more
isolated culturally if you had the
world's greatest super weapons you
probably start acting a little
xenophobic too that's why over time
Valyrian started to look the way we
think of them now with the silver gold
hair and the purple eyes the show
changed that I mean they didn't do the
purple eyes the producers just said that
they didn't look good on camera which is
a little bit weird but that's why
generis and Viserys didn't have them
whenever we saw season 1
some of you may have noticed how some of
the characters hair colors have changed
just a little bit since the pilot
episode - Tyrion was the biggest change
I think you know he went from Lannister
blonde to the really dirty mix that we
saw in season four he was only drawing
the first time I saw it I mean by the
time season four rolled around you don't
notice these changes quite so much so
over time Valerians are mastering
dragons with a combination of blood and
fire magic enchanted items like the
dragon horns and sorcery there was all
kinds of magic being practiced inside
the freehold the show hasn't really
addressed magic and great detail but I
do think by the time we get to season
six and seven they will I just think
that the more learned characters like
the more bookish characters like Samwell
Tyrion and Varys they'll probably be
given a lot of that exposition Jon Snow
is totally awesome when it comes to
brooding but he is not quite the scholar
that some of the other characters are I
would say one of my minor complaints of
the book so far is it it has said
nothing about how Valyrian actually
tamed dragons I'm sure George R Martin
will totally explain that at some point
there's a lot of things he's probably
just waiting to deal with but the really
important takeaway is that affinity for
dragons became a genetic thing it's tied
to Valerians blood which is why they
practiced a lot of selective breeding
that by itself raises all kinds of
issues like increased risk of negative
genetic anomalies but the doom pretty
much took care of all the sister wives
it's one thing when one family like the
Targaryen stew it when you have a whole
culture doing it it gets a little crazy
so one of the most critical periods in
the expansion of the Valyrian Empire was
its war with the ghiscari empire before
Valyria expanded all over the eastern
continent the ghiscari were the greatest
civilization right now where we are on
the show you really only see their
legacy in the architecture around
slavers Bay but as we spend more time in
Mereen during season five we'll probably
get a better look at some of the really
cool buildings the pyramid and the
fighting pits are only the beginning the
Valyrians had five really great battles
with the ghiscari after the fifth one
the final one they raised their land
planet with salt so that the ghiscari
would never be able to grow crops again
that was pretty much the end of them
then the Valerians continue to expand
unchecked they learned one really
important thing though from ghiscari
culture slavery
remember the ghiscari were the ones that
originated slavers Bay the biggest
reason that the Valyrian stook slaves
from all over their empire was
because they needed people to mind the
14 flames the 14 flames were a big ring
of volcanoes but they were also bringing
up or from the earth so that's where
they got all their precious metals
everything to build Valyrian steel as
well as gold other precious minerals too
they just needed a lot of people to mine
it really important thing about Valyrian
culture even though they seem a little
tyrannical they have a lot of dragons
very powerful very fearsome they were
much more democratic than a lot of the
other cultures they weren't ruled by a
single individual everyone that had a
stake in the freehold as in shares like
you'd have in a company had a vote but
during really important periods
sometimes they'd appoint a single
decision-maker sometimes they use
political marriages to consolidate power
but there are also a lot of other ways
in relationships they develop with
cities later in the expansion the
Bolivians actually inspired the creation
of the Free Cities as well as the
migration to Westeros you know people
moving into your land fearsome you move
away cohort and norvos which are
actually right here were founded during
religious schisms during the expansion
old volantis and lists right here were
actually originally created to be
trading colonies set up by wealthy
merchants who had purchased the right to
rule as clients of the Valyrian freehold
as opposed to subjects so if you are
really rich you could buy the right to
rule a city as a result they got to
appoint their own leaders the Bereans
wouldn't send in like an Archon on
draggin back or anything
in other cases cities like Pentos and
laureth which are actually right here
chose to pay tribute so whenever the
Valerians came with their dragons they
were just allowed to retain their
infrastructure just as long as they kept
paying tribute one of the really special
exceptions is Braavos which was actually
created as a secret city by a bunch of
slaves the story goes that the Valyrian
had a couple slave ships sailing around
the Summer Isles the slaves revolted
took over then to get as far away as
possible
sailed all the way to the other side of
the Eastern continent the northern side
and founded Braavos there they were so
afraid of the freehold coming after them
that they kept their city a secret for
hundreds of years till after the doom so
the interesting thing is because they're
slaves they were taken from all over the
place so they all had different cultures
different gods
that's why Braavos has so many different
temples we are going to see some of the
city in season five I don't know how
many episodes they're going to spend
there but here in the middle of town is
where you can find the biggest temples
all different gods
all very cool so when you look back on
it Braavos the Free Cities very
important to the rise of Valyria but
also a big part of its legacy I will
spend more time talking about all those
different cities like the Free Cities as
well as Braavos and future bonus videos
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything feel free to let me know if
you want to talk about certain cities
first and I'll just put them higher in
my list but the rest of hilarious
history is a little more well known like
the doom of Valyria was a giant
Cataclysm like the eruption of Vesuvius
on Pompeii think about this way Vesuvius
was one volcano the 14 flames were 14
volcanoes so when they say doom it was
literally hell on earth it's written
that it only took a couple of hours for
the entire Valyrian Empire to just
crumble into dust there are a lot of
theories about what caused the doom I
just think it was a combination of the
Valerians over mining the volcanoes
there were geographical changes that
were happening naturally and I think
there was some magic involved just a
confluence of events that blew the
out of the southern end of the continent
up down here and blew a giant cloud of
dust into the air that killed all the
dragons that were flying around tied up
and all that was obviously the escape of
the Targaryen family we know about that
Daenerys the dreamer saw the vision in
our Targaryen took his family to
Dragonstone along with five dragons the
most interesting thing about that whole
story is that only one dragon survived
from the original five that they brought
the dragon stone it's not explain why
but eventually more dragons were hatched
from there we get really tied up in a
gaunt conquest as well as the rise of
the Targaryen families so we can talk
about that in another bonus video as
well as dragons specifically let me know
that what's your favorite thing about
villarin history and do you think that
any of the characters in current day are
actually going to travel to where
Valyria used to be George Martin has
confirmed that we're going to go there
in flashbacks he hasn't said anything
about going there present-day though
just more awesome things to look forward
to speaking of which congratulations to
this week's book giveaway winner kal-el
Greece you win a copy of world of Ice
and Fire
be sure to message me on my channel or
Twitter or Facebook for details the next
book that I'll give away will just be
whenever I post my next game of Thrones
bonus video which will probably be in
like seven eight days so I also have a
big update on the telltale games Game of
Thrones game I know there's a lot of
games in that sentence now we know that
there will be five distinct playable
characters all from the same
house they didn't confirm which house it
is but I think it's not going to be one
of the main houses from the books of the
TV show I think it's going to be house
Forrester that would just fall in line
with what they did with the Walking Dead
game they created Clementine and used
characters that were not from the comics
of The Walking Dead TV show they also
confirmed this is really important it's
going to be out before the end of the
year we will be able to play it before
2015 just plan on December they haven't
announced a specific date but I'm
thinking December sometime I will
totally be giving away copies whenever
they release it and I'll be doing some
gameplay videos I know I'm really
excited for that but in the meantime you
can click here to learn all about the
city of Braavos and you can click here
to learn about some of the big changes
season 5 is making to the books thanking
you so much watching so it's all high
five and I will see you guys tomorrow